don't call it the cuban missile crisis
even that didn't end as badly as this
one did
mark cuban recently promoted a crypto
that has now
blown up in his face thanks to some
degenerate
crypto farming the coin is called titan
it went from four dollars to 60
inside of a week and then immediately
crashed to less than a penny in a few
hours
uh mark cuban in response tweeted this
i got hit like everyone else crazy part
is i got out
thought they were increasing their tvl
enough then
bam more like boom ladies and gentlemen
welcome to d5 now in the aftermath
people lost
millions maybe more memes are being made
to memorialize the event
and mark cuban is curiously suddenly
calling for a stablecoin regulation
he says in a statement to bloomberg
there should be regulation to define
what a stablecoin
is and what collateralization is
acceptable
you know i obviously agree with this
idea of stablecoin regulation but
i gotta admit losing all your money and
then calling for regulation
it's a bit like trying to ban gambling
right after you got cleaned out in vegas
i mean
you might be right bad timing it's all
i'm gonna say
but honestly i think this is a good time
to talk to all you degenerates out there
okay
trying to yield farm your way to the
moon now look we've all been there you
got that stimmy check
and you're looking at index fund returns
the s p might get you eight to twelve
percent a year
if you're lucky cash is trash you can't
keep it in fiat
so then you look at crypto boom
a hundred percent gains baby over
here 12 000
gains guys crypto is a whole new level
of risk
reward that the world is really still
getting exposed to and used to
it's it's just gains are ratcheted up
and so are losses though to be honest
people don't even open up binance or
kucoin for anything less than
200 apy and it's got y'all all kinds of
messed up okay
even people like mark cuban like here's
a guy who goes up on shark tank and he
is
he's buttoned up right he's asking
questions you'd expect
from a millionaire you know what's your
cash flow who are your competitors
what's your projected growth you know in
other words he's a rational
businessman he's he's been around the
block but apparently
when mark goes home gets in front of
that macbook
starts checking out these d5 projects
this man becomes
a filthy degenerate these were the kinds
of yields
mark was looking at uh here's a
liquidity pool
promising 347 percent apy
here's another one promising 133
000 apy and here's another one offering
you know just a a low low 4 billion
percent apy
if you put money with them now if you're
thinking there's no way mark cuban would
be
you know taken in by such ridiculous
returns right clearly these are scams
well you'd actually be right he didn't
go in for the 4
billion or even the 300 instead
according to the blog where he uh
shield this coin called titan he said he
got an
annualized return of about 206
guys don't worry we're not talking about
anything crazy here
just 206 on his money per year
now this is completely nuts so today
we're gonna break down what went wrong
with the crypto mark uh promoted in this
in this
blog post that he posted only a few days
ago it's called the brilliance of yield
farming liquidity providing
and valuing crypto projects june 13th
in this post he describes the degenerate
behavior but the token we're going to
talk specifically about where he lost
the money
is called titan but it's actually part
of a two token system that makes up an
algorithmic stable coin called iron the
two tokens are
iron and titan they both collapsed
now you should already be familiar with
the concept of stable coins from our
tether video
remember that collateral is the thing
backing the token so
like let's say i give you a token that's
supposed to be worth a dollar
my collateral could be like a dollar
that i hold in reserve
right instead of that titan admits that
it's only partially collateralized and
uses
algorithmic minting and burning
protocols to maintain a soft peg
to the dollar now if you're already
bored to tears like i am i'm just gonna
put this on screen for you to read from
them
this is how the iron titan token works
now uh
while you read this and try to parse out
what this says
let me just tell you the obvious even
the basics of this
are very complex which is something i
should have addressed a long time ago
but i might as well address now
i'm gonna say this once extreme
complexity and finance
is bad okay as an investor it really is
anyone
you should avoid them why because the
less you understand something ladies and
gentlemen
the more you can misunderstand the risks
okay like
imagine investing is like white water
rafting
it's a rewarding dangerous activity with
twists and turns
but if you know where the rocks are you
know you can be
safe you can avoid some of some of the
pitfalls it's always going to have a
level of danger
but if you know what's going on in the
river you're going to be
fine but imagine you go in completely
blind you don't know where anything is
you don't know the river layout you
gotta wash up on the rocks
you know bleeding wondering what
happened this is the case with investing
if you do not understand something in
investing you're gonna smash into those
rocks and it's
it's gonna be a problem this is why
warren buffett frequently says
that he doesn't invest in a lot of
companies it's not because he thinks
they're bad
it's because he doesn't fully understand
them
according to him by the way not only is
it true that complicated financial
schemes can hide fraud it's also true
that
just because you didn't fully understand
it things can get out of balance this is
actually what happened in the 2008
financial crash subprime lending led to
mbs's and then cdos which all confused
and
obfuscated the fact that the system was
broken
and people were still continuing to lend
loans they should have never lent
had things been more clear this might
not have been a problem
and so the same thing applies to crypto
if you don't understand these tokens
please do not invest in them so where
does that leave
us with the iron titan token the token
actually was only the beginning of the
problem mark cuban was also
engaging in something called a yield
farming through something called a quick
swap
it's just like more degenerate okay
according to a blog where he promoted
titan a few days before the collapse
he said quote i'm a small lp for quick
swap i provide two different tokens die
and titan that enable quick swap to
offer swaps between
these two tokens so now not only are you
dealing with sort of a shaky
algo stable coin add a little bit of
defy
yield farming to the mix and ladies and
gentlemen we have a recipe for disaster
even mark cuban admits he didn't do his
due diligence on this
before writing his blog post about it he
says even though i got rugged on this
it's really on me for being lazy the
thing about defy
is that it's all about revenue and math
and i was too lazy to do the math to
determine what the key
metrics were which all leads us to june
16th
only days after mark cuban writes this
about titan
and drew tons of new investors to the
project and literally one day
after iron dot finance the people who
create these little coins
itself had claimed that uh titan was a
bear proof asset oh the sweet irony
of saying we're unstoppable it's like
it's like being on that titanic but the
shift counts
so anyways on june 16th not to rub it in
the unthinkable happened a few people
start selling titan
and it led to everyone trying to run for
the door at the same time
when that happened titan collapsed to
zero along with iron
as well people really hadn't considered
that maybe what made titan make so much
money
on the way up would also make it crash
just as hard
as the post on reddit would explain best
this is how the protocol was designed
positive feedback loop on the way up
negative feedback loop on the way down
boring technical jargon in the middle
and then it says this creates both
massive deflation and massive inflation
depending on which way the supply demand
is going
it seems that this uh bear proof asset
hadn't considered the idea that maybe
their math wasn't as solid as they
thought
well millions of people lost all of
their investment or most of it
ironically
mark may have actually been one of the
people the few people who saved some of
his money from disaster because in his
response he had said
i got hit like everybody else crazy part
is i got
out thought they were increasing their
tvl enough
here i think he's referring to the fact
that he got out of the d5 yield farming
but was still holding some of the titan
which went to zero
uh some clearly didn't get out at all
such as this post from reddit he says
what the hell happened i put
23 000 today on matic titan lp
token for 1 billion apr this morning
and this was so trash i went down from
23k
to 67 cents how does your coin drop from
60 down to zero you better fix this soon
yeah this uh this really happened to
this person i don't know how you help
them i don't know how you explain to
people that
a billion percent apr is automatically
going to be a scam
i think it can be answered using a
comment i got on twitter
this is in response to everything
collapsing it says well even
mark cuban got rugged pretty normal in
d5
it's risky but you can make insane money
with ponzis
now i don't know exactly when we all
stopped thinking ponzi schemes were bad
but
i feel like there's this new logic that
maybe i should give an obligatory bad
idea to
which is that people think if only i get
in on the ground floor oh
it's a ponzi sure but you know if i just
getting on the ground floor to be fine
if it is a ponzi get in on the ground
floor
to the moon like this is obviously pure
nonsense and for the health of your bank
account
stay away from anybody who tells you
this meanwhile the lovely team
over at iron finance the people behind
this whole thing they're ready to push
another one of their uh stable coins
they say
in response to this giant collapse quote
we have learned a great deal from the
incident and while there was nothing
that could be fixed in the current
system
we will continue our journey with more
products
in the future that these guys don't even
say sorry
you could control f sorry in their
post-mortem
they don't care they don't care about
wrecking you guys they go they go hey
we're gonna start a new one like
tomorrow
uh total clowns like and i would say no
one's gonna trust these people again
but honestly crypto's the perfect place
for criminals to launch new careers
off topic guys anyone hear about that
new uh brian rose d
fight
anyways that's kind of besides the point
uh i just hope this serves as a
cautionary tale listen
titan was a billion dollar token that's
billion dollars
of value that was just blinked out of
existence
and you know for those of you who are
looking for those mouth-watering yields
it's a good lesson that always the old
saying
turns out to be true in the long run if
it sounds too good to be true
it probably is oh yeah and also remember
it might be fun to play high stakes
poker you know at the big boy table
but if you don't got it like that like
don't bother right when mark cuban loses
his investment you know in titan
it doesn't matter not to judge most of
y'all don't have
flying lamborghinis in my audience you
got to play a different hand
you know when you when you get wiped out
it's a much bigger deal
so unless you have a flying lambo i
banish you
from investing in things you don't
understand please guys
you know be safe out there keep your
money safe that's all i'm gonna say
anyway thanks for watching and i'll see
you guys next time
hey you took my money away
[Music]
you said that it was safe but i'm loved
and i don't feel okay
[Music]
i trusted you you said that it was all
right
[Music]
oh but now i'm broke and my wallet